not everything that's good for you has
to taste like kale juice and be
disgusting cacao is the powder that they
use to make chocolate which as you all
know is quite delicious and as it
happens it's also a very potent
superfood it might be a powerful brain
enhancing new atrophic and also a very
effective muscle builder as well so stay
tuned and let's find out more about that
[Music]
so raw cacao powder is the stuff that
they used to make dark chocolate but did
you also know that there's a weird trend
starting on line of people nor ting it
yes that's right snorting cacao powder
the stuff that they use to make
chocolate because apparently they can
get small high from it that's not what
I'm recommending and I'm not advocating
using chocolate to get high however it
does show you that it has some very
potent and interesting active components
and these components can be used to not
only increase brain power concentration
etc like many other nootropics
but also to boost muscle mass I say that
it's tasty actually raw cacao powder is
not tasty it's incredibly fitter like
eating a coffee bean but fortunately
it's nice dark chocolate then you can
get many the same benefits as you would
do from the raw cacao itself it's not as
good and depending on how strongly dark
chocolate is how dark you'll get more
benefits and less sugar and less milk so
you want these really pure like 90
percent or 80 percent stuff and again
it's still going to contain sugar and
still going to be it's still essentially
a sweet got calories and it says do be
careful but if you normally eat
chocolate you know as your snack and why
not swap it for dark chocolate which I
think tastes very nice and which will
gain you all these benefits as well as
we'll see in a moment there are a lot of
benefit so let's start with the
neurotropic aspect of dark chocolate or
raw cacao powder how does it boost brain
function and concentration what comes
down to several teeth first of all dark
chocolate contains theobromine this is a
dancing much like caffeine that is a
slight stimulant it increases the heart
rate slightly loose focus therefore has
a half-life of about 10 hours that last
longer than caffeine and is also
slightly milder
so if you're something like to pick me
up some caffeine and use it to
concentrate harder at work but maybe you
find it makes you a bit jittery then
dark chocolate or cacao powder is one
way that you can get it co relief or
co-wrote me
but theobromine is definitely not the
most interesting part of dark chocolate
from a brain-boosting perspective more
interesting is something called -
etiquette Achin which is a substance of
a concern that right - substance s
flavonol that increases vasodilation
i've talked about this before and
various other videos vasodilation widens
the blood vessels allow the blood and
oxygen to get around the body quicker to
the muscles into the brain in this case
we're interested how it helps blood and
oxygen get to the brain so this can give
you a slight brain boost make you more
focused and alert in theory and this is
also the mechanism of action for many
other than popularly traffic's like
vinpocetine or skin Coble / so that's
one way that it can give you a slight
boost as well but at the same time dark
chocolate and cacao powder might also be
useful as a mood booster because it
helps you to increase the production of
oxytocin the love hormone serotonin the
feel-good hormone and ananda mies the
bliss hormone
these are all endorphins they make you
feel a lot better and and amide in
particular is interesting this is the
one that you produce when you take
marijuana and it's sort to enhance
creativity in things of course you're
not going to be high like I said from
eating dark chocolate we don't need to
worry about that it might explain why
some people get some benefits from
snorting raw cacao powder that might
also be explained by the vasodilation or
it might be a perceiver effect but
either way eating dark chocolate will
give you a slight boost in brain power
by increasing circulation to the brain
by waking you up via caffeine and
theobromine yes because dark charcoal
also contains caffeine and they can
boost your mood and when you combine
these different effects you could have a
nice synergistic you know lightly picked
up so not too wired effect there's
likely many other things going on here
as well it contains those very tall for
instance which boosts the performance of
the mitochondria thereby enhancing
cellular energy efficiency this is
something that's been shown in other
cases to do spraying pro as well so it
could be all kinds of things that make
dark chocolate or cacao powder a handy
new atrophic point is though plenty of
studies to back up its effectiveness
increasing concentration etc and many of
these studies one is looking at dark
chocolate or raw cacao powder they're
just looking at regular chocolate and
they found that people who ate chocolate
regularly actually had improves the
brain performance over those people who
never ate chocolate this was shown in
some very long issue journal studies you
know over a long period of time with
large samples and now we know there are
some potential good reasons for that so
I'm not saying this isn't a limitless
tool by any means or I'm saying is for
this you want to eat something sweet and
also potentially get a brain boost then
pick dark chocolates I think whatever it
now I just adjust to the video that was
waste there's also a ready-made
nootropic products available that
includes raw cacao powder is called iqt
also contains regular cholinergic sim
poster team and caffeine and footage of
the guy to make it then they seem like a
really good bunch looking for after
their priorities in the right places
hopefully I might be working with them
in the future this video is in no way
sponsored by them however I just thought
I'd mention it because if you're looking
for a product that contains raw cacao
powder then that is one and seems to be
quite good and now on to the muscle
building effect first of all your ears
might just pricks up when I was talking
about the effect the dark chocolate
could have as a vasodilator of course
bodybuilders are also very interested in
vasodilation because it increases blood
supply for the muscles it also increases
the sense of pump which a lot of
bodybuilders really enjoy gives you that
swole feeling that you get after doing
just a few repetitions it's the - epic
assertion that increases the
vasodilation and it does this by raising
nitric oxide and many bodybuilding
supplements aims at increasing nitric
oxide and more recent studies have shown
that nitric oxides might also increase
the number of satellite cells which are
around the muscles in which the body
uses in order to repair muscle damage
clinging back the muscle fibers Vickery
stronger this is thought to be one of
the main mechanisms of hypertrophy but
more interesting in that is the fact
that - epicatechin
might also work to reduce the amounts of
myostatin by increasing fall estaphan
which reduces myostatin I definitely
said
in the very best way possible basically
dark chocolate can decrease myostatin my
assassins we don't like because it
breaks down muscle tissues produced
naturally by the body at the same time
as cortisol usually when you're hungry
and it seems to encourage the body to
break down muscle tissue to use as
energy and to make the body more energy
efficient in studies where animals have
been genetically modified in order to
remove their production of myostatin
they increase their muscle mass by
something but like 30% with no
noticeable side-effects one human child
was even born with no myosin production
a natural genetic mutation and they were
as a baby they had massive cars and
could apparently do the Iron Cross so if
you could completely get rid of my stuff
in you'd be like a superhero you'd be
super strong without even having to go
to the gym sock chocolate will not
completely reduce your myostatin it's
more like to have a very tiny affects
the amounts of - epicatechin
you'd have to consume you wouldn't
possibly be able to get some dark
chocolate without becoming a fatty which
we've kind of reversed the whole point
of boosting the muscle in the firstly
there are pure - ever Capuchin
supplements that you can take in order
to do this I don't know if they've been
tested or series and effective but all
I'm saying is if eating large amounts of
mine pepper castien can boost your
muscle mass greatly by reducing my
stuffing then eating small amounts in
dark chocolate might be able to have
some positive effects and again I'm
talking about replacing your regular
chocolate snack with dark chocolate and
if that can also enhance your muscle
mass then why not seems like a
no-brainer to me so that's what I'm
doing at the moment anyways this has
been shown to be effective in Studies on
human trials we've seen humans have
noticeable drops in their myostatin
levels and increases in follow statins
and those same participants saw their
grip strength increased by 7% there was
no control groups in that particular
study but it's all very promising so
like a fake each app was dark chocolate
and keep an eye on this epicatechin
supplement see if they get good reviews
and things because it's certainly
interesting and I imagine I'll be
finding its way into a lot more
supplements please dark chocolate is
also packed with other nutrients is high
in fiber magnesium zinc
potassium super good for you you might
as well again replace your regular milk
and chocolate processed Mars bar that
doesn't contain anything good and just
tons of calories with dark chocolate
which has fewer calories and much more
goodness in it so it's not empty
calories and things like magnesium and
potassium these are great for the brain
and for bodybuilding also also very
interesting is that rocks that have
positive effects on blood pressure on
your heart rate on your skin it's not
all good nothing is all good
unfortunately dark chocolate is also a
diuretic and committee go to the toilet
a bit and occasionally I do find that I
have that problem myself taking it but
most people there that issue I guess
I've just got them stomach
it also can increase omega-6 fatty acid
and omega-6 fatty acid you don't need to
increase because we get enough of that
anyways and when you have too much
omega-6 and not enough to make it three
it causes information in the brain and
omega-3 just please even further and
Omega please very quickly because it can
increase cell membrane permeability we
get into that now but if you're going to
take a lot more dark chocolates then I
recommend an omega-3 fatty acids tablet
so I would recommend that anyway that's
a supplement that anyone can benefit
from and as they all that wasn't good
enough dark chocolate is also one source
of resveratrol one of the most popular
antioxidants that increases
mitochondrial function and it's just
all-around really good for you
so yes doctor outlet is not going to
change your life it's not going to turn
you into the guise of limitless anymore
it's not going to give you a massive
muscles but it might support brain
function and muscle development and it
packs with good stuff it's certainly
better than milk chocolate so if you
want a good snack I recommend some
sticks of dark chocolate and if you find
it a little bit thicker
apparently adding salts can be nice I'm
not fond of doing that but I do like to
have it with a cup of coffee and the
coffee's bitterness counteracts the dark
chocolate bitterness and it's delicious
so give it a go
thanks so much for watching guys hope
you found that interesting and useful
let me know in the comments what you
think will you be eating dark chocolate
now have you been doing so already and
I'm just late to the party
what other super foods or Neotropics or
muscle pieces would you like to cover in
the future if you did find this video
useful then please consider liking it or
sharing or subscribing it helps me out
immensely and I'll have much more
content like this and also not like this
on the way soon if you'd like to hear
about that then please do subscribe and
I'll catch you next time bye for now